the k70 series has been announced in
2014 and its newest edition the k70 rgb
pro comes with a slew of new features
and a sleek design as always
let's talk about it
[Music]
out of the box the k70 rgb pro looks
really beautiful and feels really solid
in your hands other than that you have
your instruction manual there is a 1.82
meter usb c to usb a breather cable for
your keyboard and lastly there is a
magnetic soft wrist rest that you can
clip on and off as you will when it
comes to the wrist rest this sound
really surprised me it doesn't feel
jarring or off-putting because other
companies use a little cushion and your
risks are always sinking in which makes
it very comfortable to type with the
soft wrist pad is solid and keeps your
hands where they need to be without
slipping off but of course remove it or
use it as you will without the way let's
go to the highlight of the k70 rgb pro
the keyboard itself i mean just look at
that that's one handsome looking
keyboard wow
even with the plastic bottom it feels
premium as heck and it doesn't feel
hollow and the fact that they use a
single piece of metal for the top makes
it so easy to look at also the keyboard
comes with these lines at the bottom so
you guys can run your headphone wires
through it or just any wires that helps
with cable management the adjustable
height stands are open sideways as
opposed to upwards and it feels a lot
sturdier especially when you're
frantically typing or gaming speaking of
gaming there is also a tournament switch
at the back of the keyboard which locks
macros and sets its lighting to red and
you can change the colors in the iq app
so that you can focus up and not
accidentally hit keys that will cost you
your match there's also an additional
lock at the back of it so that you or
anyone else doesn't fiddle and disable
it while you're gaming there are also
hotkeys at the top the first is a
profile switch the k70 rgb pro has 8
megabytes of on-board memory and can
store up to 50 profiles that you can
come up with in the iq app say you have
a work profile a gaming profile or video
editing profile it's really helpful when
you take the time to map and plan out
what you need to save even more time in
the near future you can also map out key
combinations using the on-board macro
recording by holding the windows lock
key for two seconds there it is it's
like right there hit the keys you wish
to record press the lock key again and
lastly press the function key and the
key you wish to save it with on the fly
to open tabs programs type out sentences
you name it also you can change your
keyboard lighting settings by hitting
the function key and pressing from one
to zero which makes switching so easy
the next key is the brightness hotkey
for you know adjusting the brightness of
your new k70 rgb pro per key rgb
lighting like
this and lastly a windows lock button if
you do have a habit of hitting it
accidentally also the little acrylic
panel at the top shows you when you have
engaged the windows num and scroll locks
and if you have the caps on of course
and moving to the left we have this
smooth volume roller
and a mute key more audio options are
these media control keys you can stop go
backwards forwards pause and play this
keyboard really does everything you need
without feeling overkill and when you
think it stops it doesn't so let's talk
switches we have both models and they
use cherry mx red and blue rgb
mechanical switches but you do have
other options such as silent red brown
and speed silver i've been fiddling with
the cherry mx blue variant and it's
rated for 100 million presses and the
actuate around 2.2 millimeters with 4.0
millimeters of travel distance and i
chose the blue variants because i like
them tactile and clicky
of course with the cherry mx red variant
here as well irregardless they both feel
really great to type with on top of that
we get full and key rollover and 100
anti-ghosting which makes this one
helpful typing experience
they sound pretty good but of course you
type it on a metal surface so there'll
be a slight ping but if you're using
headphones or if you're not bothered by
it at all you know this should do fine
also talking about the pvt double shot
pro keycaps with standard bottom rail
these are solid at 1.5 millimeter
thickness and they resist wear tear
shine and fade so long as you don't do
anything too drastic
now let's start axon by corsair which is
an mcu a microcontroller unit that
offers extremely low latencies ultra
fast scanning rates processing and a
crazy polling rate at 8000 hertz that
basically means your pc will be more
responsive to your keyboard at about
eight times faster in theory it has a
0.25 millisecond average latency and a
1.25 millisecond transmit time and
honestly for your average follower this
crushes all of your expectations the
ones you have and the ones that you
don't have out of the box it's polling
rate is set to 1000 hertz so it's
compatible on older pcs however if you
want to change it to 8 000 hertz you
need to use the iq app
go into the iq software for a bit there
are loads of options for you to
customize your colors profiles keys and
more to customize your keyboard manage
your recorded macros and create new ones
easily by selecting the assignment type
i'm going for launch app select the key
you'd like to bind it to and the
modifier i prefer the function key and
for this i'll put down the geek culture
website and voila the key has been
assigned
you also have full customization options
when it comes to lighting effects down
to each individual key there are preset
key groups and you can make your own
there are some ready profiles available
on the iq website iq of course works for
mac and pc but not the xbox so if you're
planning to use it for the xbox load up
the profiles onto the keyboard via your
computer and then use the profile button
to switch your lighting profiles under
the performance tab you can customize
the win lock button besides disabling
the windows button you can also disable
the alt tab alt 4 and the shift tab too
lastly update the keyboard's firmware
and change up the polling rate to get
the full axon experience in the advanced
settings all in all corsair has had a
new benchmark for the k70 keyboard
series and it has been an enjoyable
experience typing on the script that i'm
reading out right now so if you're
looking for a keyboard that's ultra fast
and built to last make sure the k70 rgb
pro is up there on your list because
it's definitely one you should consider
if you have any questions about them
leave them in the comment section down
below and i'll do my best to answer them
the best way i can don't forget to
follow us on all of our socials and like
and subscribe to us because we have tons
of content coming your way to fill your
hearts minds and gaps in your day this
is inio signing off
[Music]